bye
as we're moving into part four of
descartes discourse on method we're
reaching what i would like to call the
metaphysical heart
of his position that he's presenting to
us here and we're seeing a long extended
argument that is is important for us to
focus on step by step by step
because
here's where descartes is is really
displaying his originality
and the fact that he is beginning from a
radically
new position in philosophy that is going
to be able to talk to older physicians
and present a coherent perspective
as a rival or alternative to other
positions
so
what we're going to begin with
is what we call methodological or
hyperbolic doubt
now when we talk about something being
hyperbolic we mean being over the top so
you know when you talk about somebody
being a drama queen for example and you
say
wow that guy you know when his team
loses he goes out and gets totally drunk
and cries over in a corner and you know
that sort of thing that's being
hyperbolic you know the law unless
somebody like mortgage their house is
supposed to you know make bets with
their bookie
that's not the sort of behavior that you
would really expect to be appropriate to
that situation it's hyperbolic
decart is going to
do something like that
with doubt
and why is he going to do that he has
something in mind he wants to as we said
raise the entire foundations that means
sweep everything else away except for
maybe a little shack to live in for a
while the provisional morality and the
rules and method and then rebuild on the
basis of what he knows he's talked about
the morals for example of previous
authors as being beautiful palaces that
are built on foundations of sand so when
you try to live in them they collapse
he wants to get away from that and the
one sure way to do that in his view is
to adopt a method of doubt now what does
that mean a method of doubt it means
that he is saying i am going to
apply this
as a principle to everything
whether i like it whether i don't like
it whether i believed in it whether i
didn't believe in it i'm gonna apply
this to everything i'm gonna reject
anything that can be doubted and i'm not
just gonna reject it as well i don't
really know about it or i can't place
trust in it he's going to say
all of that is false
now that is a huge step
it's one thing to say i don't know
something to be true
it's another to say
that over there is false
he's not saying that he knows it to be
false as a matter of fact some of the
things that he's going to reject he's
going to get back in the end and say
well they didn't turn out to be false at
all but he doesn't know that they are
true so he wants to treat them as if
they're false
now
when he's talking about what he is
rejecting he runs through them very
quickly and you notice i've got three
main subheadings here i want to go over
each of these in considerable detail in
part because in this work he is running
through them in a very summery manner
um if you read his other work in which
he discusses this sort of thing the
meditations on first philosophy the
entire first meditation and part of the
second are actually concerned with these
sorts of sorts of questions these sorts
of issues so it can be explored in much
greater detail and i want you to feel
the weight of what it is that he's
talking about here
so let's look at sense perceptions what
do we mean by sense perceptions anything
that we're receiving through the
intermediary of sight sound
um taste
smell
the various senses having to do with
touch we know there's more than just one
because there's pressure and heat and
softness and roughness and all that sort
of thing
okay so do our senses ever deceive us
are they completely reliable or are they
sometimes unreliable
do we ever like say when we're
in a dark place
or
we're you know kind of sleepy
or we're under the influence of some
sort of you know prescription drug or
intoxicant do we ever see things that
aren't there or don't see things that
actually are there
i think the answer is yes unless you
have perfect uh senses and even if you
do you're probably still gonna miss
something because that's that's part of
the way our mind works
descartes brings up all sorts of
examples and other works of like you
look at the distance and a square tower
actually looks round you put it one of
the famous ones you put a stick into
water it looks like it's bent but it's
not really bent and we could go through
all sorts of examples of these sorts of
things
sense perceptions can
uh
mislead us they can delude us
so we have to reject all the information
that is coming to us through the senses
we reject anything that we believe on
the basis of the senses
now does that mean just the things that
i'm seeing or hearing
not exactly
it goes further than that
anything that somebody told me that they
saw
came through their senses but then it
came to me
through my senses maybe i misheard them
maybe they misspoke
anything that has been provided to us
through the medium
of the senses is unreliable
and we have to reject it
so what would that mean
that would mean the rejection of all
history
of all hearsay
of anything that human beings have
recorded throughout time
that's an awful lot isn't it
it would mean that you would have to
doubt right now everything that i'm
telling you as well as their opposites i
suppose um
so sense perceptions that covers a lot
of ground
that's already taking away
quite a bit
descartes is going to go even further
though in his hyperbolic doubt
you might say well if i reject
everything that's coming from the senses
i can at least rely upon
my processes of reasoning i can use
argument i could you know perhaps even
reconstitute the world of the senses by
doing something with empirical
observation and probability but even if
i can't do that i can at least be sure
about say the truths of mathematics
but have you ever made an error in
mathematics
i know i sure have and i was a math
major in college i used to make stupid
mistakes all the time like forgetting to
include a negative sign then you wind up
with the wrong answer at the end or you
misread something
is it possible to make
similar mistakes not just with respect
to mathematics
but with respect to our other reasoning
processes is it possible to
make invalid or unsound
arguments to ourselves
to carry out processes of reasoning and
inference that don't actually turn out
to be
vertical
it certainly is descartes talks about
this he says
there are men who make mistakes in
reasoning even concerning the most
simple matters of geometry and who
create paralogisms what are paralogisms
they're things that seem like they're
true but they're not actually
arguments that that are going to stand
up if we look at them so it's possible
that anything that we think is a proof
from reasoning
is actually
false
it's doubtful
it's unreliable
now that takes away an awful lot more
than just the world of the senses and
remember descartes has talked about you
know
the body
and
the mind
maybe if we get away from what we get
through the body we can at least rely on
what we're getting through our mind
not so he's saying
if we're going to apply methodological
doubt we have to say anything that we
can't actually prove to ourselves
right now
we can't trust anything that we thought
was proved to us in the past we're going
to get rid of that
that includes an awful lot doesn't it
like who you are
or
what you're engaged in right now
or whether you have a past
or what kind of being you are
this covers like i said an awful lot of
ground
by now if you're actually doing this you
should start to feel a little anxious
and quite often when people are reading
descartes for the first time
a response that's perfectly
reasonable i suppose although you know
do we have a proof for it no we don't uh
is to feel like well what can i actually
depend upon and that's what the card is
trying to do he's trying to strip away
all the things that we take for granted
and say we can't actually depend on
those let's find what we can
he goes even further yet
maybe we're not even awake
maybe we're just hallucinating maybe
we're in a dream state
is it possible for us to tell the
difference between being you know in a
dream state or being awake
not at this point he says
and this is a very famous argument that
descartes is going to make
later on in the meditations he's going
to develop this at greater length
involving you know the possibility that
we could be being deceived by an evil
demon or a you know evil genius that
devotes all of its its efforts and
attention to deceiving us giving us
false information think about movies
like the matrix where these people are
not actually living the lives that they
think they are engaged in but are just
you know bodies in in these these kind
of tanks with a bunch of things jacked
into their head and they're off in the
computer program hallucinating that
they're working in an office
hallucinating that they're living a life
hallucinating that they're having you
know
relationships or eating lunch or being
pursued by things now think about our
dreams think about all the crazy stuff
that happens in our dreams i remember
here's one you know classic example
that's exactly what descartes is talking
about i remember when i was working on
one of the jobs that i've worked a lot
of jobs that i would call crappy jobs
you know for near to minimum wage
lots of hours
bad working conditions
just because i had to and i was working
at this this pizza restaurant
i would open
uh and then i would open and then close
and then open then close you know day in
day out um in parks i wanted the
overtime
and i remember going to sleep one night
and having a dream in which i worked an
entire shift
an eight-hour shift
and it was very vivid i remember all the
things because i you know i was spending
all my time there anyway it was it was a
summer job
and so you know i was putting things
into the fryer and cutting up potatoes
and making pizzas and making chicken and
taking stuff out and taking taking the
trash out to the dumpster and then after
the eight o'clock after the eight hours
were over i remember punching my time
card
and soon after that i woke up
and i was
mad
because i woke up to the fact that now i
was gonna have to go to work for real
after i had just worked an entire shift
inside of my dream that i wasn't going
to get paid for i felt like i should
have more overtime that week
well
can you be sure that right now you're
not hallucinating
can you be sure that what you're
watching in this video isn't somehow
being piped into your head
that you're not laying comatose
somewhere
with you know dr sandler's videos
running through your brain
if you can't be 100 sure
then how would you be sure
then you have to assume
that this waking reality that we're in
is not really there
and now it probably feels like the
entire bottom has fallen out from under
you
that's what descartes wants to do that
it's a necessary part of the argument
that he's making so where can we go from
here we've doubted everything
do we simply have
nothing
left that we can rely upon
or is there anything that we can have
complete confidence in
here's where descartes is going to do
something that he by the way is not the
originator of saint augustine uh in one
of his works has this this famous
sentence if i am being deceived i must
exist
because in order to be deceived there
has to be something to be deceived
namely the me and descartes is going to
say look if i am engaged in doubting
doubting doesn't just hang there and
avoid a void of nothingness
what's doing the doubting
here's where he comes up with his very
famous statement
kojito
ergol
which means
i think
therefore
i
exist
if i am engaged in the process of
doubting
then i must exist otherwise there's
nothing to do the doubting
we can say this about any of the other
modalities of thinking if i am choosing
i must exist if i am thinking about
something i must exist if i am feeling
something
like in having an emotion i must exist
if i am rejecting i must exist if i am
accepting i must exist any of the things
that we count as thoughts imagination
memory any of that stuff that so long as
there's a thinking there must be a being
that is doing that
this is what descartes is going to call
his archimedean point
and the idea is that
the world is is pretty darn big right
but if you get a lever long enough
you could move the entire world
the thing is you would need to find some
sort of fixed point
that you could use to leverage and then
you could do that and that fixed point
is what we call an archimedean point
because archimedes was the guy who came
up with this idea descartes believes
that in i think therefore i exist he has
found the archimedean point we often
call this the cartesian kojito
after i think
so he says um
this is here's how he frames it
i who is doing the thinking had to be
something now the question is what is
that something
and here this think is going to be the
clue
another way we can say this is i am a
thing
that
thinks
i am a thinking substance that is what
it is to be a human being for descartes
so not only is he sort of leading us
away from hyperbolic or metaphysical or
methodological doubt bit by bit by bit
he's also discovering what it is to be a
human being what is most essential to us
he says
this was so firm and so sure that all
the most extravagant assumptions of the
skeptics would not be able to weaken it
so i could accept that as the first
principle of the philosophy i was
looking for so i examined with the
tension what i was and i saw that i
could pretend i had no body why could we
pretend we had no body because maybe all
of our sense perceptions are false maybe
we're actually having a dream but maybe
there's no body that's having the dream
maybe i'm just a mind maybe i don't have
any corporeal
substance or manifestation whatsoever
i can imagine that can't i ca you can
imagine that you can imagine that all
you are is is a brain and not even a
brain but a mind somewhere that's
experiencing things
but you can't do the same thing
with the fact that you think
so he says
i could not pretend uh i can i can
pretend that the body doesn't exist the
world doesn't exist i couldn't pretend
that i didn't exist in the very act of
thinking about doubting the truth of
other things it very clearly and
certainly followed that that i existed
whereas if i had only stopped thinking
i would have no reason to believe that i
existed so i recognize he says that i
was a substance whose essence or nature
is only thinking
our essence
our substance
is
thinking
this is why we are our minds and not our
bodies according to descartes we can
imagine our bodies not to actually be
there we can imagine that the whole
world is an illusion but we can't
imagine not if we follow it through that
we don't exist and that we don't uh
think because we do
so he says
i recognize i was a substance whose
essence or nature is only thinking a
substance which has no need of any
location and does not depend on any
material thing so that this eye
that is the soul or the mind whichever
you want to call it is entirely distinct
from the body
so what we have here is the mind
and the body
are totally
separate
if there is a body at all we should put
body question mark
totally separate from each other two
entirely different kinds of things the
mind is not the brain the mind is not
something that is in the body the mind
is something that in some mysterious
unexplained way so far is connected with
the body because you know i can think
about i want to move my arm i want to
move it back
but it's not the same substance as the
body these are two radically different
things
so he says
even if the body were no longer there
the soul could not help being everything
that it is
so that's a really important
set of achievements
are we stuck with nothing note here no
we have the human being
that understands its very nature now can
we get anything more than that can we
you know do you want to be stuck in
methodological doubt knowing who you are
but not knowing anything else about the
rest of the world probably not so
descartes says
what is it that's necessary for a
proposition to be true and certain what
is our criterion for truth
and certainty
um
that's a good question how do we in fact
know things to be true how can we get
out of doubt
what how does it work in your life
do you just sort of somebody tells you
something and you're like oh yo sounds
good to me you know i'll accept that
daycare would say that's not the way to
go because
hearsay
or your sense perceptions is not going
to give it to you
how do we in fact know that something is
true how can we be certain about it
he says well let's think about this how
did we know that that was true and
certain
so he says having noticed that in the
sentence i think therefore i am there's
nothing to assure me that i am speaking
the truth other than i see very clearly
that in order to think it is necessary
to exist i judged i could take as a
general rule
the point that things that we conceive
things that we can see
clearly
and
distinctly
oops
those things are going to be true and we
can be certain that they're true
now what does it mean for things to be
clear and distinct this is not language
that you're you're used to thinking
about so clearly means that there's no
obscurity in it you know exactly what
you're talking about
there's you know there may be some
things that seem kind of mysterious
about this but if you think it through
we know what it means to think we know
what it means to exist
we know what it would mean to be a thing
that thinks
we know that you know the body and the
mind what it would be for them to be
totally separate
so if we have clear
propositions
if we really understand what it is that
we're thinking about or talking about
that's clarity
distinct means that we're not blurring
things in together we're not mistaking
one thing for another
we can actually separate them out think
about descartes rules of method right
the first rule of method was this
hyperbolic doubt second rule of method
was to take all the difficulties that we
run into break them down into their
parts
look at each part separately that is to
treat them distinctly
we're doing that with the mind and the
body right here the mind is one thing
the body is another thing
if we want to understand the nature of
the body we have to look at the body if
we want to understand the nature of the
mind
put the body aside and look at the
nature of the mind don't bring up mris
or brain states or stuff like that
look at what it is that you do with your
mind reflect on that descartes would say
and you can have clear and distinct
knowledge
about
these sorts of things
so he says
um
that left a single difficulty of
properly noticing which things are the
ones that we actually conceived
distinctly
so
what have we achieved so far
we've inflicted this hyperbolic doubt
upon all of our experiences all of our
reasonings everything that we are
and we took away an awful lot
then in that absence in that void we
found something that we can rely upon
and in finding that we were actually
doing that we were actually enacting
that we were discovering
what it is according to descartes what
we really are
every one of us can follow along with
descartes story and say i am a thing
that thinks my entire essence my entire
substance is thinking
my mind and my body are totally separate
then we found something else we can in
fact have some knowledge about something
beyond the fact that i exist and the
fact that i am a thinking thing because
if something is clear and distinct i can
say that i can rely upon it now the
question that we want to ask is
all right what is clear and distinct
what else do i know